an update now on nevada's road to
recovery the governor and the state
treasurer held their final town hall
regarding the american rescue plan funds
bianca holmen live to share more about
these listening tours bianca
good afternoon so there's been several
almost oh just over a hundred listening
tour stops and town halls and events for
the governor and the treasurer to gather
feedback from nevadans on where money
should be spent and they've been doing
it by collecting these surveys
nevada has 6.7 billion dollars to
address the impact of coven 19.
some of it has already been given to
local governments during the height of
the pandemic
state leaders say spending money is easy
investing is hard major feedback from
the public includes investing in child
care good paying jobs affordable housing
and education more than 2 000 proposals
have been submitted we're going to work
with state agencies and experts in the
field as well as an outside consultant
to help connect ideas to different pools
of money that are out there the
complexity of this federal money is is
so important to know about because
there are 107 different buckets we're
going to be extremely transparent about
the proposals the vetting of the
proposals the proposals that have been
selected how they're going to be funded
absolutely you know we're going to roll
that out in the weeks and months ahead
now both the governor and the treasurer
recognize that nevada was hit very very
hard by the pandemic ground zero as what
many said and then also that it's very
important that we spend the money wisely
to set the next generation up for
success bianca holman live local now we
certainly weren't impacted so many
people bianca thank you